[Musik]
sebastian lege verrät euch wie veganer
käse hergestellt wird
was macht die vegane variante so teuer
und schmecken die tester den unterschied
zum original
wir machen den test wigan käsescheiben
ähneln jungen gouda
den gibt es im supermarkt schon für
unter 70 cent pro 100 gramm
die veganen alternativen kosten über
einen euro mehr
das gleiche gilt für pizza käse auch
hier ist das tierische produkt mit im
schnitt 1 eur 13 viel günstiger als die
vegane konkurrenz nicht anders sieht es
bei frischkäse aus vegan ist er sechs
mal so teuer und auch beim parmesan
watte preisunterschiede das vegane
produkt ist pro 100 gramm zwei euro
teurer
branchen-insider sebastian lege weiß mit
hochwertigen zutaten hat das alles
nichts zu tun mit einem eigenen vegan
käse bilder zeigen wie bei der
herstellung gespart wird als milch
ersatz nimmt sebastian mandl wasser dazu
vermengt er 20 mandeln mit rund einem
liter wasser im mixer mandeln sind reich
an fett und protein und schmecken nicht
zu intensiv
[Musik]
fertig ist die mandelmilch erinnert
wirklich an milch ist aber deutlich
günstiger als das tierische rohprodukt
für ein kilo käse alternative braucht
sebastian nur 20 mandeln die kosten
nicht mehr als 30 cent
milch ist teurer selbst bei einem
erzeugerpreis von 33 cent pro liter
denn für ein kilo käse braucht man rund
zehn liter
macht zusammen über drei euro die seit
er viel fett wir brauchen die veganer
alternative kokosöl davon ordentlich
das geht aus der kuhmilch sorgt beim
käse für konsistenz und geschmack
sebastian nimmt für sein vegan produkt
250 gramm kokosfett zusätzliche kosten
gut 1 euro dann nehmen wir hier unser
mandl protein wasser damit sich die
mandelmilch jetzt mit dem fett verbindet
gibt er beides erneut in den mixer
notfalls hilft ein emulator aus soja
[Musik]
super basis jetzt fehlt natürlich der
geschmack käse aroma hochkonzentriert 1
2 tropfen reichen um pumps schmeckt
alles ablesen reicht für die farbe sorgt
beta carotin eine winzige menge genügt
fehlen noch etwas stärker als
bindemittel und salz für den geschmack
alles gut mixen und fertig ist die
vegane kreation mit käse geschmack
sieht schon mal sich aus machen wir mal
eine kleine gegenprobe farblich so
geht's nicht so schlecht traditioneller
käse braucht viel zeit um farbe
konsistenz und geschmack zu entwickeln
oft wochen monate oder gar jahre
für seinen veganen pseudo käse kocht der
produktentwickler die mixtur einmal kurz
auf schon verbinden sich wasser fett und
stärker miteinander
[Musik]
draußen werden hände pudding
für sagen der zieht fäden wie echter
geschmolzenem käse
insgesamt hat sebastian waren im wert
von rund 2 euro eingesetzt und auch der
zeitaufwand ist gering
die mixtur muss nur noch abkühlen um
schnitt zu werden
fertig ist die käse alternative in einem
kilogramm echtem gouda stecken mehrere
liter milch und eine lange reifezeit
legis turbo käse ist schon nach ein paar
stunden fertig geworden
das kilo für gerade einmal zwei euro
sebastian könnte seine eigenkreation
jetzt als veganen käseersatz verkaufen
aber natürlich nicht ohne vorherigen
geschmackstest riecht nach käse sieht
aus wie käse ist aber nur eine
alternative da bin ich ja mal gespannt
ob da jemand den unterschied schmeckt
wir laden zur verkostung in einer
berliner markthalle appetitlich
angerichtet und serviert auf einem stück
brot kommt uns jemand auf die schliche
merken die tester das darf kein käse aus
milch ist
wie die akquise den europa immer
gegessen hat schmeckt ein bisschen nach
lidl gouda also wenn man einen neutralen
käse möchte mit dem ganz gut bedient
besten ist jetzt mich unbedingt
vorsitzen
geschmacklich also kein highlight der
sieht aus wie käse jahr aber hat einen
unerwarteten beigeschmack
ja so vom geschmack her erinnert der
mich an diesen typischen einzeln
eingeschweißten tost käse schmecken bis
sind so wie analogkäse viele der tester
halten die vegane käse alternative
einfach nur für billigen käse einen der
tester erinnert sie sogar analogkäse
solche käseimitat auf pizzen und
backwaren sorgten vor jahren für
schlagzeilen verboten waren wie zwar
nicht durften aber nicht als käse
verkauft werden
wenn ich mir die zutatenliste dieser
veganen kers alternative heute anschaue
dann sieht die sehr sehr ähnlich aus zu
dem früheren analogkäse denn die
inhaltsstoffe müssen weil vegane
lebensmittel nicht besser sein gerade
die veganen käse alternativen inhalten
viele gesättigte fette die der
verbraucher eigentlich eher meiden
sollte
unter den zutaten findet sich häufig
auch kokosfett und das ist reich an
gesättigten fettsäuren vegane
käseprodukte sind also nicht automatisch
gesünder und günstiger schon gar nicht
diese produkte sind relativ teuer
vegan ist hip aber natürlich bezahlt der
verbraucher dieses lifestyle produkt
denn der verzicht auf zutaten oder
hilfsmittel tierischer herkunft macht
produkte nicht zwingend teurer
das gilt nicht nur für vegane käse
alternativen auch andere ersatzprodukte
wie wurst und fleisch imitat bestehen
zum größten teil aus wasser und anderen
günstigen zutaten
unterm strich also ein lukratives kalkül
mit dem guten gewissen der kunden
was haltet ihr von der veganen käse
alternative und welche magic produkte
schmecken euch am besten schreibt es uns
in die kommentare
und wo es die besten lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt zeigen wir
euch auf unserem kanal zdf besser ist